Start now.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
the
This afternoon, I'd to share a
narration with you all
that tells us of the bare minimum
that the human being has to hold within
his heart
in order to enter
and pass under the threshold of Islam
in order for a person to be a Muslim.
The starting point then
is what is mentioned to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam here in this
narration.
It's a narration which is incredibly
important
and in it our messenger Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us of the beginning and
foundations
upon which the rest of our faith and
relationship with Allah is built. This
is the foundation. This is where it all
begins.
At this point,
the human being becomes a Muslim and
becomes eligible for paradise
and is considered a follower of the best
of mankind Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam
and a follower of all of the prophets
and messengers.
This narration is collected by both
bkari and Muslim.
What does it mean when we say some a
narration
per se is collected or reported or
documented
by Bkari and Muslim
alkari
he has
his most famous book
which is known as
it's an authentic compilation and it's
referred refer to askari.
But its name that the author originally
gave it is
that this is an authentic compilation
of the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam's
days and acts, traditions and
statements.
Alam Muslim is one of Bkari's students.
It's his most prominent student
and he wrote a book
which he intended to be a companion and
complimentary
to Sah Bkari.
It's known as Sah Muslim.
And this these two books are the most
authentic books
after the book of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Immari didn't just write
overnight.
It took him 17 years to write this book.
And he made
for every single narration that he
wrote into his
and al Muslim
based his book
largely on
Bkari and he expounded upon it. These
two books,
they're not new. They haven't just been
released 20 or 30 years ago or two or
three years ago. These books have been
around for almost 1300 years.
And these books have been rigorously
dissected
by thousands upon thousands of scholars.
and every single generation
of Muslims since
the second and third
gener
century after Hijra.
Thousands of men and women from each of
those generations have narrated Sah
Bkari and Sah Muslim.
And these two books have been agreed
upon amongst the scholars of Islam to be
the most authentic books.
And the highest level of authenticity
that any narration can have in the
science of hadith is that the narration
is what is referred to as
it is agreed upon. This word agreed upon
means that Bkari and Muslim both agree
upon this narration. Its wording, its
meaning and its chains of narration
and agreed upon though in the science of
hadith means it was reported by Bkari
Muslim.
It also holds the meaning of agreed upon
amongst the scholars of Islam
because every single narration
that is agreed upon the narration itself
the chains of narration are a different
issue but the narration itself agreed
upon
have been accepted
by the scholars of Islam one generation
passed down to the next. This narration
is of the highest authenticity
and it's a narration that is critical.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam is
narrated here by his
companion
narrates
that the messenger of Allah. Wasam
saidchech.
[Silence]
So in this narration
tells us that the messenger of Allah
sallallam
gives us the criteria of those who enter
paradise. Every human being who has
lived on this earth that will enter
paradise
after the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam after the prophet Muhammad's
lifetime and during his lifetime after
he was appointed as a messenger this is
the bare minimum criteria for entering
paradise
tells us that the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alaii wasallam said
whomever
testifies whoever testifies that none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah alone
without any partners
and that Muhammad
is his slave and messenger
and that Isa is the slave of Allah and
his messenger and his word which he cast
to Muriam and cast upon Miam and a soul
of his creation.
And whoever further testifies that
paradise is a true literal reality
and that the hellfire is a true and
literal reality.
Allah will enter him into paradise based
on his actions on whatever subsequent
obedience to Allah this person musters
up.
So we see here that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam mentions four
or five key points.
Number one, the person testifies that
none is rightfully worshiped but Allah.
This is the meaning ofahillah.ahill.
This doesn't just mean that
Allah exists or there's no creator
except for Allah.
Most people believe that in one way or
another, even if their actions or even
if the details of their beliefs may
differ, most of humanity historically
and even till today
believe that there is one creator of all
that exists.
even even religions that are known for
polytheism
and idolatry.
Say for instance Hinduism.
Hinduism, if we were to take all of its
sects and all of its different groups
and all of the different fringe
groups
all together and calculate it's said
that there are more than 20 million
different gods and saints that are
worshiped by Hindus
collectively.
Now even in this religion very chaotic
an educated Hindu
a scholar of Hinduism knows that these
are all either saints or representations
of the one true godhead
that they refer to as some call him
Brahman some call him Shiva different
sects different groups
But they still even though they have all
these idols and all these gods, they
still believe in one essential creator.
However, their belief is different in
the sense that it's a pantheus belief,
meaning that everything is God and God
is everything. This of course is
radically different than the beliefs of
Islam and Judaism and Christianity
and so forth. Even the magians in the
time of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
al- majus
they believed in two primary creators
light and darkness.
But even in that they still believe that
light was superior to darkness because
from light comes good and from darkness
comes evil.
And so
when a person deduces
deduction and reasoning
always
brings a person to the conclusion that
there can only be one creator.
So this is not necessarily unique to
Islam.
However,
Islam
is not just that a person believes that
there's only one God, but that a person
worships only that one God. This is
where the mushri of Quraysh
differed with our prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They believed that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala was the creator.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
[Silence]
If you were to ask them who has created
the heavens and the earth them here
being Abu Jah and Abu and
the people of and the people of and the
pe if you were to ask them who has
created the heavens and the earth they
would say Allah.
And so the dwa of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was that he came to
the people who believed in that one
creator
and he sallall.aii wasallam said being
that he is your only creator
then why do you worship other than Allah
worship then only Allah because only
Allah is worthy of your worship. This is
embodied in the statementahill.
None is rightfully worshiped but Allah.
And so this statement
became the hallmark of the believer
that differentiates the Muslim from all
other religions.
It is not there is only one creator.
That doesn't differentiate a Muslim from
other religions. What differentiates
a Muslim from other
religions is the worship of Allah alone
without any partners. This is where the
rubber meets the road. This is the
difference between the Muslim and the
non-Muslim.
And so here the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam says, "Whoever testifies
that none is rightfully worshiped but
Allah
alone without any partners.
[Silence]
He says
and that Muhammad is his slave and
messenger.
To Allah he is a slave. To us he is a
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala the highest
rank any person can ever obtain
is the rank of being a true servant and
and slave to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and that is why in the most honorable
mention
of our prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam
in the Quran Allah doesn't refer to him
as by his name he doesn't refer to him
by his title as messenger or prophet. He
refers to him as his slave. Subhan
one the greatest night of his life. The
most honorable night of his life. The
night when he was taken from his bed
and brought before the throne of Allah.
He walked where not even Gibl was
permitted to to walk. And he was brought
within proximity to Allah that no other
angel, human or jin had ever
been brought before Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And in this instance, in this
honorable mention,
Allah refers to him as what? As his
slave, as his servant. Subhan Allah.
Receiving the Quran, the greatest book
to the greatest of messengers. What is
he referred to as?
criterion the Quran upon his servants
etc. You'll notice this is mentioned
throughout the Quran this pattern and
that is that in the highest
honors that our prophet is given
Allah refers to him as his servant his
slave
and not only that but those who truly
obey him. He says
the slaves of Alman. These are the best
of people. Allah refers to them with
that title. Why? Because the human being
was created as a servant. He was created
as to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And
being that that is what we were created
for the human being, no matter what he
does, he will always be a slave to
something.
He can merely choose whether to be a
slave to Allah and receive with that all
honor and mention or a slave to someone
or something else.
for
[Silence]
and
so we will continue this inshall
next week.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah
Allahb
I Sh.
I shall
[Silence]
I shall.
Oh,
I s
I Father
[Silence]
Allah. Oh,
Alhamdulillah.
foreign.
[Silence]
Yeah. foram.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
for
[Silence]
There are three hallmarks.
These are the hallmarks of the people of
paradise.
These three traits, these three
attributes,
these three dimensions
of our servitude and worship of Allah,
the more intensely
they are found in a human being, the
higher this human being will be found in
paradise.
These three traits, they are the
hallmark of all goodness
and happiness, true happiness in this
life and in the hereafter.
If we were to say, what are the traits
of the people of paradise? If we were to
sum it all up,
what is it that a person is expected to
be at every waking moment of his
conscious adult life?
They are free.
He tells us in his
that the hallmarks of happiness are
three.
That when a person receives a blessing,
he is thankful.
Gratitude.
And when a person is put through a trial
or difficulty or experiences
tribulation, he is patient.
Patience.
And when a person sins and makes
mistakes,
that the person is contrite,
that the person is repentant.
For these three traits, they are the
hallmarks of happiness.
Gratitude,
patience,
and repentance.
Because every moment of your waking
life,
every conscious moment that you or I
ever have or experience,
we are in one of three states.
We are in either in a state of receiving
blessing from Allah, receiving ease,
comfort, help, security, health,
satisfaction.
And when a person is the recipient of
blessing, he is expected to be thankful
to Allah, to have gratitude.
that gratitude is so important
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala refers to
the people of belief as the only truly
grateful
or a person is in a time of difficulty,
a time of tribulation,
a time of crisis, a time of discomfort.
In which case it is the human being's
responsibility
to exhibit patience
for the sake of Allah
for the pleasure of Allah
or a person is in a moment of weakness
a moment of sinfulness
a moment of disobedience
in which a person is to exhibit
repentance.
and contrition.
And so gratitude, patience,
and contrition,
repentance,
these are the hallmarks of the people of
paradise.
Thankfulness and gratitude to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is not just lip
service.
It is a worship of Allah
and it is quantifiable.
It is not just something that you know
kind of exists or it is something that
can be quantified. It is an act of
worship.
Allah has commanded it in the Quran.
Therefore, anything he commands is an
act of worship. He says subhanahu waala
is
he says be thankful to me.
Now if we were to say how do I thank
Allah? Just salah is an act of
worship. Just fasting is an act of
worship. Hajj is an act of worship.
Every act of worship in Islam can be
quantified.
It can be defined.
And every act of worship in Islam, it
has pillars and conditions.
The pillars of thankfulness and
gratitude to Allah are three.
If a person is to exhibit gratitude,
these three things must be present in
their gratitude.
That a person acknowledges in his heart
who is responsible for this blessing,
where it has come to them from.
And that a person when he speaks, he
refers this blessing to Allah. subahala
and that a person implements this
blessing in a way that pleases Allah.
This is what gratitude is. This is how
you thank Allah generally and
specifically
for any blessing. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala gives you the blessing of a child
for instance
then your responsibility is to exhibit
gratefulness gratitude and thank Allah
how do you thank Allah
with acknowledging
that this is from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and that this is a blessing that has
been given to me not because I deserve
that Allah give me not because I have
earned it but because Allah is generous
and merciful
that a person refer this blessing to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the way
that he speaks
that a person says alhamdulillah
this is a blessing from Allah
and third that the person raised this
child in a way that pleases Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is how we
exhibit gratitude.
Allah subhanahu waala has always given
and when he gives the recipient is
expected to show gratitude.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has always
made it his allegiance
between his creation and himself.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
Allah has stated in every book with
every messenger to mankind in no
uncertain terms that if you thank me I
will increase you
and if you show ungratefulness
know that my punishment is a very severe
one.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
teaches us in the Quran and in the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam sunnah not
just how to be grateful but but how to
see gratitude truly that it not just be
superficial but that it come from every
fiber of our being.
Because gratitude is the believer and
the believer is the great grateful one.
If we were to say what is a synonym of a
believer in the Quran, what is a synonym
of the word in the Quran? It is a sh a
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has said that
he created the human being and gave him
gifts and faculties for the human being
to then choose whether to be grateful or
to be ungrateful.
whether to be a believer or a
disbeliever, whether to be a Muslim or a
non-Muslim, whether to be a follower of
the messengers or an enemy to them.
And my brothers and my sisters,
gratitude
is not natural to the human being.
This is a discipline. It's a learned
discipline.
You and I, we're not naturally grateful.
The human being naturally is an
ungrateful creature.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he says subhanah
he says subhanahua
and if you were to attempt to enumerate
the blessings of your lord you would be
unable to do So indeed the human being
is oppressive by nature and ungrateful
by nature.
But that is what the book is for. That
is what the Quran came to teach us. What
did the Quran come to teach us? What is
the messenger?
What was he sent to teach us? How to be
grateful, how to be patient, how to be
contrite and repentant. That is what he
came for.
Those are the disciplines that he came
to teach us. The human being is not
naturally grateful. For this reason,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala focuses in the
Quran on the obedience to one's parents.
Why? Because it's unnatural.
Naturally, the human being is an
ungrateful creature.
As for being good to one's children,
most people are already good at that
because it comes naturally to them.
But what they have to learn is
gratitude. And the believer
is not anything if not grateful,
especially to Allah.
And so gratitude is taught to us. We are
taught not only how to speak with
gratitude, how to act with gratitude,
but how to think and truly feel with
gratitude.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala teaches his
messenger this lesson.
He says,
[Silence]
He teaches his messenger gratitude
and he draws his attention
to the blessings of Allah upon him even
when he didn't ask
even when he was unable to ask.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala were you not
an orphan but Allah gave you sanctuary
protection?
Were you not
poor and Allah then gave you wealth?
Were you not unaware and Allah gave you
guidance and knowledge?
So as for the orphan, do not be harsh
with him.
And as for the one who asks, do not turn
him away harshly.
And as for the blessings of your Lord,
then ascribe them and thank him to to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this is how we learn gratitude.
When we go to think, we look not to what
we don't have or what we wish we had.
We look to what we do have and what
things could have been like.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam said in
the narration of
[Silence]
He said, "When you look to those
besides yourself, look to those who are
less fortunate than yourself.
And do not look to those who are
seemingly more fortunate
for that is more likely for you not to
belittle the blessings of Allah upon
you.
A person has a knack. The human being by
nature, by his very nature is usually
most drawn to that which is pessimistic,
most drawn to that which is negative.
He is most aware of that which he wishes
and that which he doesn't have. He is
more hyperfocused on disappointment
and very rarely is able to see the
blessings that he has.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
teaches us how to beware of this
incredibly dangerous trait and that is
belittling Allah's blessing.
that you scoff and thumb your nose at
Allah's blessing it's not good
enough. How does a person do that? He
tells us look to those who are less
fortunate.
You have two legs, look to those who
only have one. You have one leg, look to
those who have none.
Look to those who are less fortunate.
You have one meal a day, look to those
who have none.
No matter how bad your situation seems
to be, there will always be someone out
there who is suffering more.
It was said that
as was collected by
in his
Aubam
was tested by Allah
and he was given immense wealth and he
was given great health and vigor and he
was given a huge family with many
children. Much pride he took in that
which he had
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala praised a
yub for his patience and gratitude
and so
wished
to turn this man into someone ungrateful
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala allowed a
shan
to cross boundaries
his children and his family were all
taken from him in a moment, in a flash.
One minute he is the father and
patriarch
of a a family of 20 or more members and
the next moment in the blink of an eye
they are all gone. He buried every one
of them.
His health was so bad that he was
permanently quarantined for decades.
No one dared to come and visit him.
That all of his wealth had dissipated
till he was considered to be the
example of poverty, the epitome.
And his wife
was the only one there with him that was
enduring.
He narrates that
a couple of men passed by
a yub and overheard him in these
circumstances saying alhamdulillah.
A yub was very sick.
He endured illness to the point that he
was permanently quarantined.
People didn't even dare to come visit
him. the prophet of Allah
and he was overheard saying under these
circumstances
alhamdulillah
and they said for what
alhamdulillah for what look at you
you have nothing
you know it's very easy to look at the
half that is that is empty in the glass
and to say this is the messenger the
prophet of Allah
he's sick he has no health he has no
wealth he has no family he has no
standing
and so they said alhamdulillah for what
listen to the believer a person who
knows Allah a person who has seen the
majesty of Allah he said alhamdulillah
He said, "Alhamdulillah
that Allah has given me a tongue by
which I can still praise him."
This is how a person shows gratitude
and for this reason a he didn't even
have to ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
give him and give him. He didn't even
have to ask for Allah to heal him. If
you notice,
his dua that he made to Allah, he never
explicitly said, "Oh Allah, heal me. Oh
Allah, give me my wealth back. Give me
my family back." He never said that.
Why? Because he knows
that what Allah chooses for him is
infinitely better than what he chooses
for himself. And he's not sure. Maybe
maybe sickness
and illness is the best for him. Maybe
that brings out the best for him and
maybe health will be a hindrance and
will jeopardize his relationship with
Allah perhaps.
So he never asked for that outright. All
he had to do was barely gesture
that he is uncomfortable.
In his dua he said
he said oh Allah I have been afflicted
and you are the most merciful. That's
all he said immediately.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave him and
gave him.
It said that his wife came to him and
said, "Will you not make dua to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to reverse what has
happened to us?" 18 years it said that
he spent in this state. 18 years,
never once did his faith
waver.
It said that she asked him will you not
ask Allah to reverse this? He said how
many years did we spend in comfort and
ease and wealth? She said 40 years. He
said when we reach 40 years in
difficulty maybe then I can muster up
the boldness to ask for Allah to reverse
this. This is a man who's truly seen
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Not a man that wishes away Allah's
blessings and belittles them.
Raheem.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We often times speak about the courage,
the valor, the dignity of the prophets
and messengers, the dignity of our
prophet and messenger sallall.aii
wasallam.
And we think usually when citing
evidences of their courage, of their
audacity,
their times in battle, their times in
the face of their enemies. And that
surely is a sign of courage. But a real
sign of courage
is generosity.
Real courage is forgiveness. Real
courage is the audacity to not lose hope
in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. That takes
courage. Anyone can be stingy.
That is rooted in fear.
Anyone
by nature can be ungrateful and
pessimistic. Anyone can look and say,
"Well, that would never happen to me cuz
my life is terrible." as if Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has some personal
vandetta against a person.
But real courage
is for a person to look poverty in the
eye and say, "I'm not afraid of you."
For a person to look wealth in the eye
and say, "I will spend you for the sake
of Allah."
It was said by anis in
that a man would come to the prophet Sam
to become Muslim. The only reason he
would come to accept Islam is because of
the wealth that the Muslims were
enjoying at the last years of his life.
And that everyone who was there would
know that this man came to accept Islam
only for a dunya.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
would accept his Islam and he would make
him a the equivalent of a millionaire in
a moment
that a man would come wanting only the
dunya and accept Islam. And the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam would give him an
entire valley of livestock
just because
that person would enter into Islam with
those intentions
and after being exposed to true Islam
and the Muslims and the messenger and
the Quran would only be for a few days
before Islam is more beloved to him than
the dunya and everything in it. And all
that wealth would go right back to the
Muslim.
Why? Because it is not wealth that made
the Muslims.
It is not it is not power or military
strength that made the Muslims.
It is their faith. It is their audacity
to believe.
Their audacity and boldness to have
faith and hope in Allah when all else
seems hopeless. The audacity of Moses
standing at the shore of the Red Sea
with Pharaoh closing in and his own
companions saying,
the audacity of Moses when his own
people are saying we are done. There's
no hope now. The the the Red Sea is in
front of him. Pharaoh is behind him. And
in those circumstances, he still has the
courage to say, "Allah is with me. He
will not let me loose. Allah is with me.
He will not bring me to this point in
order to humiliate me and forsake me
now. And with that kind of faith, the
sea itself will turn solid.
With that kind of faith, even the sea
will obey his stick because that is the
faith that is what gave our predecessors
that gave our our our
forefathers, our ancestors that gave
them the world in their palm because
they didn't ask for it and they didn't
want it. All they wanted was Allah's
favor.
All
speech.
foreign.
[Silence]
Allah.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
When becoming
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah.
I shall
I Yeah.
Heat.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close all
of the gaps. Align your shoulders and
your feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two neighbors on either side of
you. Please do not join a row until the
row ahead of you is completely filled to
capacity.
I
think
what you
alhamdulillah
many Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
Foreign
speech. Foreign foreign foreign speech.
[Silence]
Let me come on here.
for
[Silence]
Tell me Allahel.
Allahel.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Amen.
All
the
me Allah
Allahel
Allahel.
[Silence]
I can go
down
shadow.
No more
time.
[Silence]
Allah.
Allah want to set up.
[Silence]
I just have a few announcements
inshallah.
I imshallah every Saturday and
Sunday after fudger prayer he has Quran
for brothers where inshallah they
recite a juz from the Quran. So
please join. This is Saturday, Sunday
after faj every Saturday and Sunday
inshallah.
the youth group has an open play
time that would be after every day. So
any any youth that to join just
come in after there will be something
going on inshallah.
Also a reminder for the announcement
that we have done last week.
Basically what we have done we
designated the back part of the gym
to be a place for a a quiet time for
people who come in early who wants to go
there and pray some Quranshallah I mean
read some Quran and that's from 12:30 to
1 and then after 1:00 it's designated
for ladies sisters who come with in
strollers or they have babies they can
also go there they will be able to hear
the inshallah
And the entrance to that section is
through the parking lot. The door
will be open. There's chairs there.
There's runners there. You can pray
there. And you can join with us just
you were here. But you will be at
least with you know with your children.
please donate gener. And don't forget
to that we are doing the education
tax credit starts now. So basically,
whoever done it, it's time to start
doing it again for this year. Tax season
is coming up with us. So please take
advantage of that because it doesn't
cost you anything.